[Music]
in bad decision news
why you got a dough man submitted by
Papa boat
Papa boat 3 UCLA basketball players were
arrested for stealing in China one of
the ball brothers was the one that stole
he's just along for the ride
cuz that bull got money they don't yet
though actually but I think it's family
got money the loan
I mean taking only one one of their one
of their sons is playing professionally
right so yeah lonzo's playing well the
other two are still just kids if they're
in China though they have money right
cuz you have to have a little money to
travel
no they I think they travel as a team Oh
for the Scoob yeah what it was for you
went to Shanghai with the UCLA
basketball team because they're playing
against Georgia Tech yes it's like
exhibition game right I believe
something it's crazy how these
collegiate players are already kind of
like treated on a pro level dude if you
ever want to feel like a [ __ ] just play
a college basketball player it's great
it's fantastic how many even you to play
them and I feel like a bit that she
feels like a anime dude you know like
you just you move in the boom it's like
oh [ __ ] so then these basketball players
that went to the Louie Vuitton store and
they were shoplifting really expensive
sunglasses home and so that's when the
store called the police and the police
went over to the hotel which was nearby
of the store and start interrogating all
the basketball players to find out who
it was that was shoplifting and that's
when they decided to arrest Lee Angelo
ball Cody Riley and Jalen Hill how
embarrassing guys
how embarrassing Angelo I would UCSD so
whatever yeah it's making headlines all
over the place because my Angela he has
his family who you know as we've
mentioned his older brother playing for
the Lakers his younger brother is still
in high school but he's expected to also
go to UCLA and so here's his family and
the dad the whole family's killing I
thought I taught today all right
yeah that happened well we could say a
little bit about the Laker boy he ain't
doing as well
it's his first year but yeah I feel like
that whole family there good bit like in
terms of like like stirring the pot so
that they like people are talking about
him obviously so they're doing something
right like we're here we're here I talk
a lot a bit why would you do that why
would you he was like right like there
right there like there faint ticket to
fame is there but that's the part I'll
get like if you're at UCLA like you're
like like she's saying it like an inch
away from going pro mm-hmm and why would
you just throw away like your entire
pairs sunglass sunglass you guys don't
remember being young and [ __ ] around
but I was never young on the verge of
being something yeah you know like these
guys are young on the verge of like
literally you wait a week and there
might be an eight-figure seven-figure
contract in front of your face if your
take but a week is so long and the
sunglasses are right there were you like
they're freshmen in college I was not
like Oh Andy at this level you're
already getting cars and [ __ ] like the
schools are already buying this [ __ ] you
have your pad like that the schools are
already treating me like a pro it's not
like a Sun the sunglasses were like this
like oh my god like I gotta have this
kind of thing yeah well they're saying
that sunglasses their range from 435 to
about 2,000 oh that's still nothing it's
not about the price it's about the
thrill that's true this was defending
the deer are you invested in there in
big baller because I know or if they
wanted to do it like be more conspicuous
don't wear all you see Ellie [ __ ]
try not to be six six walking around and
you try and a land of Chinese people
like you're just gonna stick out like a
mutt like if you're a [ __ ] like six
nine and you're at the LV store the
minute you reach your hand over the
grass already everyone can [ __ ] see
your ass you mother would walk around
just doing this all I'm saying is I
remember being 18 which so so
[Applause]
they were being detained but then now
they've been released they were able to
stay in their hotel but they can't leave
the country until after they've
determined the amount that was stolen
they're gonna go to Chinese jail I know
there's if it surpasses a certain amount
then there will need to be a trial
ever but then if it's below it's
starting to mount then it's no big deal
they all they need to do is a formal
apology pay a fine oh my god they're
gonna go on like Chinese public like
broadcast being like do you like this
all solid oh sorry like that they might
get special treatment because usually
things like a horse take forever to
resolve but then because of the fact
that Trump is over there right now and
like the fact that they're American that
they might be getting special treatment
and they love American basketball too
exactly and then they might they might
just expedite this and just send them on
their way so that's why though Lavar
ball who's the father he was saying like
it's no big deal everyone's making this
a big deal that's horrible good no
that's your [ __ ] response he should
be like I'm so sorry well apparently he
was planning on doing a press conference
but then the he was advised not to and
then so when paparazzi were near him
that's when he made that statement like
everyone's acting it's a big deal it's
no big deal it would be resolved quickly
that make it a big deal you [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah you're a piece of trash like
reminds me cuz like you know our friend
keno was like stuck in like Indonesia oh
yeah three months you know it was it was
a thing with like her visa and her and
her like her performance there or
something her show like the promoters
didn't process her paperwork right so
they made an example of her and they
held her passport and held and they were
supposed to go to trial for like you
know doing business when they weren't
allowed to his stuff but it's like but
yeah but then like these guys just
because they're like you know
celebrities or whatever they get to just
Express they should put the promoters on
trial because they're the incompetent
lazy ones that didn't do it right right
right it's not the performers fault
right well in that case yeah but this
one here because if he gets held there
that he can't even play he can't
continue people ready they've already
said that these players would not be
working in that
game against Georgia Tech that's a
submission game what about the actual
season we will know whether or not this
good if we can't play in the season then
he might not get like drafted yeah yeah
big deal can he get kicked off the team
for doing something bad and making a
team look bad they're all cash cows at
this point dude he's so [ __ ] annoying
dude I I like the confidence I do I hate
that we I hate that we are talking about
it yeah he's winning in a sense even
though we're talking [ __ ] about him he's
still winning yeah he's a stage dad oh
for sure he's a stage dad to poplar
before I was reading it to him I know he
said that he said you he said that he
could be Michael Jordan one-on-one what
if he played he'd been like a little bit
of like college basketball like yeah but
he's like his stats his average stats
are technically better than Michael
Jordan's over Michael Jordan's career
place because they're only taking like
two games or something like technically
like his stats are better and he said
yes that's why he's so obnoxious like
it's hard to like the guy you know what
I mean and I think like people's
arguments about him is that well he's
building his brand for his kids and
they're good but at the same time it's
like you're setting them up to fail of
my opinion for himself - he said like
Alonzo ball like Jews I mean he's not
doing come he's a rookie you know I
didn't mean but people look at him like
he's supposed to be the goat yeah and
now that he's not doing as well they're
like he's garbage garbage but like you
know but that's the pressure that you
know you created from where's their mom
do they like is their story about their
mama she's she's really sick so she I'm
not sure what she had per say it might
have been some form of cancer but she
was like really really sick and that's
where she was going to buy her she got a
lot better than damn how you do that
when your mom's sick she's still around
yeah I saw that when they were the
paparazzi he was like we'll chill oh
shoot maybe like it's actually like a
really sad story and he's just like
trying to be like this you know
sunglasses for his mom that's what
you're trying to do we got it all messed
up
he was doing some nonprofit work yeah
stealing from the rich giving to the
poor Devin yep I wonder what it's like
to be a basketball player dude just to
be walking around and people just throw
[ __ ] at you don't you get that now
yeah yeah but but the quality of [ __ ] I
get is just so Oh Mary
well Muriel is not is not random low
[ __ ] first of all she didn't give a
[ __ ] about who I was she ignored my
calls for to move through your dick at
her through my eye straight up through
the sausage in her face that she's like
deflect the point through like this many
and it just came right back my Wonder
Woman this is what I'm talking about
though this is like the the lowest of
low and these aren't even fans by the
way fans are like really cool you know
you had to have conversations with them
like I was at you know that the taco Joe
Avenue 26 right and so we were there and
this person looks at me she goes oh my
god David Choi nope
tell her what I know no David Choi I was
like close but no it's okay a picture
with no because you don't know you know
she just sees somebody that might give
her some type of and I'm the lowest I'm
like a negative Z celebrity you know to
be like how low are you to really want
that much attention for somebody like me
the come on man yeah it's so crazy
though that's the people I'm talking but
they're not fans Korean yeah no yeah
sometimes I'll get approaching like
Julia yeah come on out I just want to
know how it feels like to steal some
Louie Vuitton sunglasses and get away
with it again
I really miss again no I mean I just
again as in like stealing again yeah I
think last week movement to get shot was
so much it cuts it like a bark did they
yeah and I was like it's Joe oh I'm
sorry I was nervous that have a lot to
like they'll say like oh I was nervous
that's why I forgot your name and I'm
like no yeah we were we were at the
Taiwan Airport right we were like in the
we were kicking it and then a fan came
up to you and he's like Phil no no he
didn't say Phil he was like aren't you
from Wong foo any he's
no you guys yeah you are you know what I
think it is though I think some
decisions
this is I think sometimes they don't
know what JK is but we were in your
video and then still Joe Joe from Wong
foo and I'm like what video are you
talking about they saw the the single by
31 oh yeah and then they never seen any
of the JK stuff so but let's see oh yeah
no I've definitely gotten like like
people say oh I've seen like oh yeah
yeah you did the here is the the condom
parody and I'm like a JK video and I'll
be like I don't feel like explain to
them no so actually there's another guys
and they did this one in the other like
you have to get into this whole
conversation it's just easier to just
say like but David Choi though that's
pretty bad like it where do we just look
nothing alike
they just switch the names in there it
was it not like with me and Julian like
they've know us but they forget who's
name belongs to who it literally wasn't
good like she couldn't even name a video
or anything that I was in I think she
just saw me by glancing and it was like
oh because if it's different like it's
like Oh David Jose cuz you know we both
somewhat sing and I could see that now
they know anything about me not somewhat
sing David you're a singer
[Music]